>> Greg: CAN ELECTRIFIED BRAIN
CELLS IN A CLUSTER WHEN ALL THE
GAMES AT DAVE & BUSTER'S?
SCIENTISTS HAVE TAUGHT LIVING
HUMAN BRAIN CELLS IN A DISH HOW
TO PLAY THE VIDEO GAME PONG AND
MAY HAVE TAUGHT DEAD ONES HOW TO
WRITE FOR JIMMY FALLON.
[LAUGHTER]
USING ELECTRIC CLOSEST TO
STIMULATE THE CLUMPS OF CELLS IN
A GAME WORLD WHICH SOUNDS BETTER
THAN HUMAN BRAINS WE EXPERIMENT
ON, RESEARCHERS SHOW IMPROVED
PERFORMANCE IN THE GAME FASTER
THAN AI'S MEANING THEY A CLUMP
OF BRAIN TO BE A COMPUTER AT
PONG.
THE STUDY OF BRAIN CELL CLUSTERS
AND DISHES IS NOTHING NEW.
PONG PLAGUING MANY BRAINS ARE
THE FIRST TO BE SHOWN PERFORMING
GOAL ORIENTED TASKS WHICH CAN
OVERWHELM SOME OF THE FINER
HUMAN BRAINS.
SO THIS IS CONSIDERED A MAJOR
STEP TOWARDS THE CREATION OF
SYNTHETIC BRAINS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY, IT CAN'T COME
SOON ENOUGH.
LIKE SCIENTISTS MAKING A
CORONAVIRUS MORE INFECTIOUS, WHY
ASK WHAT COULD GO WRONG, I SAY?
ALL RIGHT, EMILY, PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND, OKAY, SO, IF THOSE
BRAIN CELLS OR WORKING ON THEIR
OWN, THEY ARE LIVING IN A
UNIVERSE THAT THEY BELIEVE IS
ONLY THERE UNIVERSE, RIGHT?
THERE UNIVERSE IS PONG.
IN THAT WORLD, THEY ARE
LITERALLY LIVING IN A
SIMULATION, WHICH MEANS AREN'T
WE LIVING IN A PONG WORLD?
SOMEBODY ELSE IS DOING THE EXACT
SAME THING TO US WE ARE DOING TO
THE BRAIN CELLS.
THEY JUST PROVE THE SIMULATION
WORKS BY MANIPULATING BRAIN
CELLS TO PERFORM AN ACTION WHICH
IS WHAT IS BEING DONE TO US
RIGHT NOW, EMILY.
>> THAT IS MATRIX.
WE JUST NEED --
WHAT?
ANYWAY.
HERE IS WHAT IS SO GNARLY ABOUT
THE ENTIRE THING, WHATEVER,
EVERYONE.
HERE IS WHAT IS SO GNARLY.
THE CRAZIEST PART IS THAT THIS
BRAIN LIKE WORK IN, WHICH IS
DISGUSTING, THAT THING LEARNS.
IT LEARNS.
THAT MEANS YOU CAN PUT ONE IN
EIGHT JURASSIC PARK FRAMEWORK.
IT IS LITERALLY LIKE TONY, THE
HUGE GUY LIKE BASICALLY THE
HUMAN BRAIN INTO ANYTHING
TERRIFYING AND THAT THING WILL
LEARN HOW TO TAKE OVER.
SO TO YOUR POINT, YES, THIS IS
THE MOST DANGEROUS THING WE'VE
EVER HEARD ABOUT IN OUR LIFE.
>> Greg: SHE MISSED THE POINT.
SHE MISSES THE POINT.
>> WE ARE IN THE MATRIX.
>> Greg: IT SHOWS THAT HUMANS
CAN CREATE UNIVERSAL
SIMULATIONS.
THAT IS WHAT IT SAYING!
>> YES, I WANT TO GET OUT OF IT
NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
WHEN YOU TO WHERE -- I THOUGHT I
NEED TO LEAVE THE SIMULATION.
I DID.
BIKO RIGHT.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, THERE IS A
GROUP OF SCIENTISTS BELIEVE THIS
IS WHY WE DON'T FIND ALIENS.
>> RIGHT.
>> THEY ARE IN THEIR MICRO
UNIVERSE DOING THAT AND WE ARE
NOW JUST REALIZING THAT IS WHERE
WE ARE.
I FEEL BAD FOR WHOEVER'S
GRANDPAS BRAIN CELLS WERE THROWN
INTO THE SCIENCE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE'S IN HEAVEN
AND A PIECE OF HIM IS RIPPED
AWAY.
LIKE THAT POOR GUY.
IF WE ARE IN THE MATRIX COME I
WANT TO BE IN THE FIRST ONE.
I DON'T WANT TO BE NUMBER FOUR.
>> Greg: LAST WORD?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT PONG IS
BECAUSE I'M SO YOUNG.
[LAUGHTER]
SORRY, IT'S TRUE.
I DON'T WANT MY TECHNOLOGY TO
HAVE BRAINS.
BRAINS THAT PEOPLE JUDGE YOU.
I DON'T LOVE MY PHONE TO HAVE AN
OPINION.
>> Greg: INTERESTING.
>> ON WHAT I DO ON MY PHONE
>> Greg: AGAIN YOU MISS THE
POINT, TOO, IT'S AMAZING.
PEOPLE AT HOME UNDERSTAND WHAT I
MEAN, RIGHT?
WINK.
UP NEXT THEY TELL USERS WHAT
THEY CAN AND CAN'T SAY BUT WILL
THAT FINALLY DRIVE PEOPLE AWAY?
[APPLAUSE]
Your record label
is taking off.
But so is your sound engineer.
You need to hire.
I need Indeed.
Indeed you do.
Indeed Instant Match instantly
delivers quality candidates
matching your job description.
Visit Indeed.com/Hire
Why do nearly
one million businesses
choose Stamps.com
to mail and ship?
No more trips
to the Post Office
No more paying
full price for postage
and great rates
from USPS and UPS
Mail letters
Ship packages
Anytime
Anywhere
For less
A lot less
Get our Special TV Offer
A 4-week trial
Plus postage and
a digital scale
Go to Stamps.com/try
and never go
to the Post Office again
I GOT THIS MOUNTAIN BIKE FOR
ONLY $11. DEALDASH.COM THE FAIR
AND HONEST BIDDING SITE. THIS
KITCHENAID MIXER SOLD FOR LESS
THAN $26. THIS I-PAD SOLD FOR
LESS THAN $43. AND THIS
PLAYSTATION 5 SOLD FOR LESS THAN
A DOLLAR. I WON THESE BLUETOOTH
HEADPHONES FOR $20. I GOT THESE
THREE SUITCASES FOR LESS THAN
$40. AND SHIPPING IS ALWAYS
FREE. GO TO DEALDASH.COM RIGHT
NOW AND SEE HOW MUCH YOU CAN
SAVE.
Guys, your masculinity is
too important to trust
to weak, outdated formulas.
Test X180 from Force Factor
is powerful,
helping you boost
total testosterone.
Build muscle,
increase energy,
and improve
performance.
Rush to Walmart for Test X180
from Force Factor.
Guys, do you want to be the
ultimate man?
Alpha King from Force Factor
unleashes an
epic surge in total
testosterone,
helping you
build muscle,
increase strength,
and leave her breathless.
Rush to Walmart for Alpha King,
from Force Factor,
the #1 fastest-growing men's
health brand in America.
>> Greg: ARE PEOPLE GETTING
BETTER ABOUT FANS ON TWITTER?
ANNOUNCEMENT EIGHT JOE ROGAN
OPEN AN ACCOUNT ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM WITH FREE SPEECH AND
DOING SO JUST IN CASE [BLEEP]
TWITTER GETS DUMBER.
TWITTER PERMANENTLY BANNED
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE OVER
COVID MISINFORMATION.
LAST WEEK THE PLATFORM AND FOR
ALL IT JUST ROBERT MALONE BEFORE
HE APPEARED ON ROGAN'S PODCAST
ALLEGEDLY OVER.
MEANWHILE THE MODERNA AND
ADMINISTRATION WITH THOUSANDS OF
RETWEETS.
I WILL STOP THERE BECAUSE I'M
BORED BY THIS TOPIC.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, CATS
COME I DON'T KNOW, IS SHE
RELATED TO JONATHAN TAYLOR
THOMAS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> YES.
YES.
SPILLING GOOD, GOOD, GOOD.
BIKO >> Greg: THE STREISAND
EFFECT YOU ARE AWARE OF THAT,
WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT
SOMEBODY UNTIL SOMETHING IS MADE
OUT OF THEM AND THEN EVERYBODY
KNOWS WHO THEY ARE.
>> THEY ARE THROWING THESE
PEOPLE OFF OF TWITTER LIKE THE
DUDE, SPITTING BACK LIKE ONE OF
THE INVENTORS OF THE VACCINE.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, THE GIRL
FROM THE SITCOM.
>> Greg: YES.
>> SHE WAS SPITTING FACTS TOO
FROM THE FEDERAL WEBSITE.
>> Greg: BUT SHE DIDN'T COUNT
THE FACTS CORRECTLY.
SHE SHOULD HAVE CONDITIONED IT A
LITTLE BIT.
TO TAKE ON THIS WEIRD TREND.
>> I TRIED TO JOIN MYSELF BUT
I'M NOT VERY GOOD WITH
TECHNOLOGY.
SO I ENDED UP SENDING OUT A CODE
ON TWITTER.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY DID THAT,
DID YOU SEE THAT?
>> THEY TOLD ME TO ALTHOUGH THEY
THOUGHT I WAS HACKED.
THE MOMENT WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SAID --
AND I WANTED TO ANNOUNCE THAT I
AM ON ALREADY BUT I'M NOT.
>> Greg: IT WAS A WEIRD THING,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE JUMPING TO
IT AND IT MADE ME FEEL LIKE IT
WAS MORE LIKE PALOR.
>> I WILL MAKE THIS FAST.
>> Greg: PLEASE DO.
>> THEY WANT TO CENSOR MORE BUT
THE ANSWER IS CENSORING MORE.
THEY SAY THAT THE FREE MARKET
REGULATION FAILED.
AND THEN YOU HAVE CONGRESSMAN
LIKE CRENSHAW WHO PROPOSED NEW
LEGISLATION THAT ESSENTIALLY
AMEND SECTION 232 TO OPEN AND
IMPROVE ACCESS, TO PROHIBIT
POLITICAL CENSORSHIP.
SO PEOPLE SHOULD FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY ARE DOING AND EXTEND G.O.P.
WHEN IT IS FOR FREE SPEECH OR
LACK OF CENSORSHIP.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES THIS HAVE
TO DO WITH JONATHAN TAYLOR
THOMAS?
I BET IF WE MET, WE WOULD BE
GOOD FRIENDS.
>> I'M SURE.
>> Greg: WOULD WE HANG OUT?
>> YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE
POSTING FACTS THE WAY THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
HOW LONG WILL LOCK DOWN LAST?
PICK A COLOR.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> Greg: DR. FAUCI SAYS IT
WILL LAST AS LONG AS IT WILL
LAST.
>> PUT THAT ON TWITTER AND SEE
THAT IT WILL GET BANNED.
>> Greg: WHERE AM I?
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
Liberty, Liberty ♪iberty,
Only pay for what you need.
♪ Liberty, Liberty,
Liberty, Liberty ♪
Such tree-mendous views.
I'm at a moss for words.
When a cough tries to steal
Dad's punchlines,
he takes Robitussin Naturals
powered by 100% drug-free
ingredients.
Are you gonna leaf me hanging?
Soothe your cough naturally.